hey GQ I'm Chris Stapleton and these are
my
[Music]
essentials all right for this essential
first let me go get
it this chair was the chair that was in
my breakfast area growing up there were
there were four of them originally and
they were kind of a yellow vinyl when I
was a kid my mother kind of recovered
this one in the late ' 80s I think and
it kind of traveled around with me um
kind of went to college with me or VAR
living situations with me but it's
always been with me it's been my guitar
chair that I kind of sit around and play
guitar in every time I go make a record
the chair comes with me and right now I
get to sit in the chair for a different
reason but that's the story of the
chair this is a 1964 Jazz Master this
was the first nice old guitar I ever got
and it was a gift from my wife when I
received it it it looked very uh
mint I kept it that way for a while and
then I started feeling bad it's a tool
to me and it's meant to be used and so I
I've used it over the years and it's
certainly in the room for everything
that I've ever recorded even if it's not
played on everything I've ever recorded
it's played on a lot of things that I've
recorded you can see over the years it
it turned very not meant just from use
but that's okay this is all Hest where
it's been a good tool and has served me
well generally I'm not playing an
electric guitar in a riding setting uh
unless I'm there in a studio with the
whole band the guitar that I would
choose to sit in a room with is about to
come
in
[Music]
this is a 1950
something Gibson LG2 it has a replaced
neck on it and replace tuners and body
probably Ed it as a canoe paddle there's
like mud in it and so many repaired
cracks that you probably can't count
them I bought this guitar very early in
my songwriting career and most songs
that I've written um have been on this
guitar these are the foundations of most
of the music that I've made in my
songwriting and record making career I
paid about $380 for this guitar it took
about $900 to make it work correctly but
it's earned its keep beyond that and I
don't know all the stories that made it
look like this but it's certainly been
with me for a lot of good ones I have a
friend of mine who talks about playing
guitar in the way that you have to kind
of throw your whole body into it when
you're in the moment of singing or
playing um if you're not putting all of
yourself into it then you're not going
to get that but I I try to do that at
all times but certainly there's moments
where you know know all right this is
not the one we're just working this out
that you're not doing that but when it's
go time uh whether it's a live show or
um recording something yeah you just go
there if you didn't get there all the
way that wasn't the one you
know the jeep that we're going to take a
look at is a 1979 Jeep chair key that my
wife purchased for me after my dad
passed away she caught me looking at it
online said hey let's get out of here we
flew Phoenix are Arizona and drove it
back uh to Nashville it was all original
at the time and had uh you know like
77,000 Mi on it and I warned her that we
would not make it all the way and we did
we did lose an alternator along the way
but since it made its way back home she
kind of regifted it to me as uh in a way
that she kind of hooked it up for some
guys at hendri racing to kind of redo
the whole thing so it's as modern as it
can be mechanically and every nut bolt
and screw on it is either refurbished or
new so it's a thing that I can get
inside and once again have lots of great
memories it's special to me in way that
I could never get rid of it and
hopefully never wreck in it in this Jeep
I wrote the song traveler my wife was
asleep in the passenger seat I was
driving and the sun was coming up over
the horizon I wrote the song while I was
driving we wind up stopping in Gallop
New Mexico that night and I had to you
know take the guitar inside and figure
out how to play it so that that was how
that song got written and ultimately
went up being the the title track of uh
debut album so the Jeep has significance
in in that
way if you're a chef or a knife
collector you know what this is It's a
knife rule this one belong to my dad and
where I grew up in Eastern Kentucky
knives would be given as a sign of
respect they were things that one man
would give to another man so my dad when
he passed away there were quite a few
knives I didn't really collect knives or
anything like that previous to that but
I had inherited some from my grandfather
and these are from my dad a lot of them
from my dad this one in particular I
know was his and I hold and I think of
them they're from various times periods
of time a lot of Case Knives them are
from the 40s up to the 60s 7s you hold
on to them you know this one was my
grandfather's um he was a knife
collector but my dad was not necessarily
and I think about them a lot I think
when I open these things up and touch
them I can feel connected to them in a
way that maybe I'm not otherwise so it
kind of got me when they passed away I
kind I kind of turned into I would I
would pick up knives and as I was
thinking about doing this I was thinking
about the sign of respecting and I
really started getting in my own head
about it thinking about well when I buy
a knife am I trying to buy self-respect
I don't really know maybe that's what
I'm doing I don't know but I but I I do
it to feel connected to my father and my
mother's father who had the all these
knives this is my grandfather's flag he
was a soldier in World War II he was
buried and this was the flag that was on
his coffin and they handed over to the
family at the end I have given the honor
of getting to keep this with me and
always kind of remember the things that
he had to do so we get to do the the
things that we get to do I keep this in
my office this stays in my office and uh
if I'm in my office riding it's sitting
right there by the wall and it's always
in the room he was a man with a 10th
grade education that wound up
engineering for a multinational cult
Corporation he was is a testament to
hard work and very very um particular in
the things that he did so all those
things you know inform some of what I do
I'm
sure this is a hat my hat that I've worn
for a long long time I had a different
one years ago that was similar my wife
gave it away to a fan at a club one
night she's like you can get another one
right and I was like well no not really
they don't don't make that anymore so I
I had to hunt for something similar this
one's better you know there was a reason
gave that one away I always kind of
loved crazy hats and the guys that wore
them the company that makes these hats
is a company called Charlie one horse
and this was made in the late '70s early
' 80s and I found it a New Old Stock and
I've worn it nearly out there's not a
there's not a band in it anymore this
one's on slap legs really so hopefully
my career will last longer than this hat
will because it's very very fragile at
this point but the guys uh and and the
ladies and the crew have have dubbed it
precious so it has a name it's a hat
with a name mainly because it's fragile
so that's the Hat keeps the lights out
of your eyes once again it's utilitarian
but it's also decorative it's been with
me on everything that I've done and when
people think of what I do I think they
think of this hat probably as much as
they think of me my great grandmother
made this blanket she gave it to my dad
when he went away to college and it sat
around in chairs in my house growing up
if it was a cold night this was what you
pulled out I don't know when it would
have been made maybe the 60s but these
were all pieces of material that my
great-grandmother had saved from mending
things it got worn to the point where
the edges of it were kind of worn off
and my mother actually kind of repaired
some of it so it has that kind of touch
to it too if I was running out of a
burning building it's it's the thing
that I would grab in my house you know
so if I want a blanket this is the one I
want this is a pair of boots made for me
customed by the uh lucasi company I was
on a radio tour in El Paso before
traveler came out or anything like that
lucasi makes really really nice boots
they take you up to this kind of Willy
Wonka room when you do the factory tour
and they're like hey we'd like to make
you a pair of boots pick out anything
you want I think they were surprised
when I was like okay I just want this
kind of very plain pair of boots they
have much more expensive versions of
things I like no I I want something I'm
going to wear every day and that's what
I did with these for the longest time
these were my everyday Boot and I wore
these everywhere and did everything in
these boots I love things that have
genuine wear on them as well and so
there's a lot of that I look at these
boots and I think about things that
we've done a lot of those things
happened in these boots they're special
to me in that way I always have a a
Filson jacket running around with me
somewhere it's this kind of wax cot
material it's just kind of allp purpose
if it's raining if it's windy or you
just need a jacket it works out for that
so it's tough you can abuse it toss it
around if a budy guy was in a band with
it used to say things like you can get
your work done in it I don't know it's
just a nice utilitarian item and I have
a lot of respect for things that work
and this is the thing that works my
personal style is absolutely completely
utilitarian I wanted just to to uh
function as a as a garment it was a
philson jacket that I wore on the sing
of the national anthem for the Super
Bowl so it works in that setting as well
thank you for taking the time to uh
watch My Essentials and I hope maybe you
learned something about me that you
didn't know or if you didn't thanks for
joining us
anyway